Hi guys. All right. Welcome to the video.
We are with parties that cook nature asked me
to tell you mental health and physical health is extremely important.
And today we're gonna learn how to.
We're going to divide into two teams and compete against each other,
where we have to make two meals with carrots and Sterling.
And I just want to say real quick that I think cooking is really important,
especially cooking healthy food.
Cause I'm guessing a lot of you programmers than college students spend most of
your time in front of the computer.
And maybe sometimes you skip a meal or you just eat ramen. Well,
as you start to get older, you'll realize that health is really important.
So yeah.
Make sure that you take care of your health with exercise and by eating healthy.
And because of that,
you'll probably be a lot more focused and can probably be a lot more productive.
All right. I'm gonna introduce you guys to some of my coworkers.
This is my boss sound, Jake coworker boss.
He tells me what to do. Is that true? Okay. What is your role
drama, your actual role? A product manager.
Exactly. That's why you're a PM.
And basically what the S people do is they answer PM questions. True.
He is my boss. Not quickly enough.
I say that here, Cyrus,
you guys probably see my Instagram stories.
[Inaudible].
And he's the guy who trains me, dude,
my hand. It doesn't even, Oh my God, my hands too small, bro.
Yo, look at that. Oh man.
What are your numbers? Yeah. No, not your peak. Your peak?
Yeah. How, how, how much did you weigh and how much did you lift?
One 45 dead lifted. Five, 10 squatting.
[inaudible] look at his posture. This is the humble brag posture.
I just look at Cyrus and I just feel massive
when I see you, I was like, can you send me some of your lifting clips?
I'll I'll put them right here.
Wow. Part of the caption. What.
A man or Cyrus? What a man.
He pretends to be camera shy, but he's actually humble. Bragging. He's like, ah,
yeah, my muscles aren't Fila deadlift
thousand pound club. Wait, what's it called? Thousand club. Yeah, of course.
Of course. Easy, easy, bro. Oh, okay. It's true.
Can you tell me about your role? My role is an engineering manager. Ooh man.
You're wow. You seem very young as hell. No,
you're not. How old are you? 20.
See, already. That's young the way you said that, Kevin, but yeah.
So for aspiring soccer, what can you tell them?
Tips to succeed in the world, check out. You almost feel you.
And then I'm serious. Um, tips
cracking the code interview.
That book lists all my jobs and that was saying practice, practice, practice.
What about once you get into the job,
how do you succeed as a thought or a full-time Uber?
I would say learn as much as you can from the most senior engineers
write more code. I think my personal opinion is
immerse yourself. Just get yourself with tricky situations,
do a bunch of random things. So basically just do it right?
Just do exactly what I tell them all the time electric. My analogy was like,
nevermind.
So just like sports. I think you have to practice,
practice and practice like in sports,
you wouldn't just read about the sport and then one day hope to be the best at
it. You know, you have to practice,
you have to put in the hours and you have to develop those muscle memories.
Same thing with coding.
You can't just read about it and try to optimize for like the best learning
experience. And again, you just have to get your hands dirty and start coding.
So I tried to infiltrate theater team and get some Intel about what they're
making.
So are you guys making Abishai I'm making parents like what's the final meal
that is more secretive than Apple. What the hell?
Unfortunately, he was as clueless as I am clearly.
People who work in Silicon Valley do not cook for themselves.
The team actually smells like a lot of veteran life.
Like we're not making anything. Yeah. It's all that butter.
Even lift bro. Oh. That smells really good, dude.
Wait, wait, let me give my viewers some sense. You guys smell it,
which you say, did you say something? What is that?
Rami? I don't touch that. Yuck. Wait, wait, can you dab it? I want to,
I need to make my touch.
Look at my down.
What? What's the hardest thing about being an engineering manager?
Artists thing? Yeah. Wait, the light is better than this side artists.
I would say the hardest thing is instead of code you're debugging people.
Oh. And when you're cutting, when it goes to the people, it's obviously not
rational or logical it's code. So it's a little trickier,
but what what's the most common problem that you have to debug and people
usually, I mean, I think the biggest thing for, for engineering engineers,
right? Do you you into like what really gets them excited for my projects,
for them, for their career, personal passion, that kind of stuff.
You definitely need to know that your engineers very well.
Nice. Fresh. Starting to heal Sanjay. Sanjay. Can I interview you?
It's okay. Oh, look at that skills.
How do you become a product manager? I be called rock manager. Yeah.
I stumbled upon it for realsies though. How did you do it?
Chose me. You actually want an answer? Yeah,
let's do a real answer. Look at the camera. Not me.
I wanted to be a product manager after school.
I was a computer science minor. Oh really? I didn't know that.
Oh. I couldn't go in and talk about it.
And so what's the next best thing of all things. Acid product manager.
Can you stop please? Uh,
and so I spent a couple of years out doing PM stuff, not doing PM.
What were you doing? Doing data analytics. That's what I do. Yeah.
I was in sequel all day. I've seen development, marketing and partnerships.
How'd you transition? I asked my boss, I was like,
my whole team had left and I was like, they wanted me to stay. I was like,
I will only say I buy the product. I'm interested in our role in the product.
And once a PM,
always you recommend people going to the data analyst if they can go to PM right
away. But do you recommend people to go to data analyst before going to PM?
I always say that in order to become a very good man,
you have to learn how to do everything else.
That's not as true when you're really bad.
You can always be a good camper straight out of just doing that from the start.
But if you want to be a great piano,
you got to learn how to all the other aurochs get together. Amazing piano.
Thank you so much. Thank you so much. Whoa, that looks heavy.
Are you jacked? Have you been working out?
Whoa. Oh man.
So this is, this is a result. Oh my God. You dropped some stars. Yeah.
So that's all right. That's all right. Well what is this? Oh,
that looks delicious. Butter. I'll be shack.
How can we be successful as a software engineer? Like yourself? Impact.
Are you stealing from other people we're done?
What do you mean by stealing impact? So you let them do the work and then Oh,
interesting. Oh yeah. I made this thing.
The vegetarian. Yeah.
You're going to have the cauliflower steak. Okay. All right. Real answer. Now,
if you want to succeed as an engineer and get promoted, what should you do? Um,
you find things that are most impactful and you work on them and you make sure
that people who are in your game agree that it's the most impactful thing.
Okay. What do you mean by impactful? I hear that word a lot.
What does that mean? It means you have a goal that you're trying to fingers,
trying to figure it out. If the funds that you're going to be working on.
So you can't just do whatever your boss asks you to do. Right. Um,
okay. Your boss,
doesn't ask you to do things so you will sometimes have to go and figure it out.
Fascinating. Thank you.
By the way, Kevin, what do you do for work?
I don't actually do anything also. Does that mean you're a product manager.
Can you tell me how you got into the role that doesn't do anything?
Because I really want to do that role.
I was optimizing for the least amount of work that I could possibly do. So
cooking is fabulous. What do you, what do you,
what do you miss most about being a software engineer? Non-manager yeah.
I miss coding. You have miscoding.
So are you saying engineering managers don't code a lot anymore.
When you have a smaller team, you do, but larger teams don't have the time.
Do you ever regret becoming a manager? No, because you like people.
I like people. Nice.
So Elton, tell me about yourself. I can tell you basically,
how long have you been working as a software engineer? For like 20 years. Oh,
wow. So you must be really, really senior [inaudible].
Oh my God. Can you tell me more about the ease? When do people start?
[inaudible] right. And you're, [inaudible]
a young, fresh,
fresh 20 now being, being 40 years old.
He's 17. How do you keep your complexion? So smooth as a 40 year old,
simple showering is overrated. Oh my Oh, overrated. Thank you.
Say I don't shower. Well, this is why,
because I'm trying to get perfect complexion. Thanks so much Elton. Well, yeah,
my flexing. No, I don't really see any definition. A little bit harder.
A little bit. We get it.
We get the kitchen. You over there.
Just take a seat and then you cook the freaking meat. Go check.
Hey, how's it going?
Oh, here we go.
So then we get that delicious chicken flavor.
Now the thing is, you know, you guys don't care.
About this jargon, this technical jargon,
because India is about what it tastes like. Right?
But most importantly is how we made it. We made it as a team harmony.
That's why, when you look at this, what does it look like? Yes, exactly.
Because it's all about harmony and bonding for teammates.
So we didn't just make this food for our hats. We made it.
Speech on a laptop.
All right. So we're getting to the
PowerPoint and see me had a very strong team effort across cross
functions, cross between our team and our project management.
We greatly exceeded expectation.
You can see, we had a nice spread of a mix of meats, vegetables,
side dishes, and meats is unbelievable.
Period of toasted.
We grilled some steak at the nice chilled salad.
And then we tossed out with a nice pineapple dessert.
So you can see we had all our milestones early two months early
and uh,
as a team to
just take that picture two seconds ago.
Holy.
Is it recording? All right.
Thank you guys for watching. Join this awesome computation.
It doesn't matter your coworkers,
but yeah, let's try this a little bit smoother.
We are at our new apartment. It's not furnished yet,
but we're just looking at it. This is my new roommate.
All right, let's check it out. What's this? Oh, hell yeah.
Are you serious? Isn't your bathroom bigger? Because it's two sinks.
Oh, I love this lighting all like the mirror lighting.
It makes you look Jack them. All right.
So probably one couch here and then a couch here, your huge couch here.
Projector on the screen. Boom.
I think it's just in case I'm gonna give you
one.
All right. So I hope you liked that quick tour. Uh,
I don't want to show you everything yet.
And also I want to decorate this place before giving it tour. So
what is it? Cause it's hot. You can feel it,
but yeah. So anyways, we're going to, we're going to go back to work now. AK,
we're going to go to the gym. Hit, hit the weights. Yeah.
All right guys. So after a long day of work, I usually like to, you know,
just like your size a little bit now, why do I exercise? You know,
I think you guys should all exercise too,
because it's really important to keep fit because obviously when you code all
day, you know, it says it's not very healthy.
Cause they're sitting around all day. And also another thing that's important.
I don't want to reinforce the negative stereotypes of programmers.
So I think everyone should go to the gym.
It's good for you because you'll code better.
And also so that we don't look like nerds. So yeah,
there's a few squats. So warm, upset issues.
Yeah. So we're going to start with 95 pounds, five,
five reps for warmup.
Yeah.
Make sure you have asked the, the grass, make sure to pop that button.
Okay.
So today we're going to try to hit a PR meaning one map. What is it?
One map rep max one rep max one rep max,
meaning I just do one rep and I want to see how much I can do. Yeah.
And he's wishing me luck.
Um, this is two Oh five. This there's two Oh five. Yeah.
All right.
My goal is to get to 15 by the end of this month
or we're going to try to source two 15 by the end. So yeah,
because I think that's what intermediate is. How much do you weigh? One 30.
Two pounds. Okay. One 30, five 30. All right.
So we're going for two 25. Yeah,
I think that would pass the intermediate level for my weight class.
Okay.
All right. Thank you for watching this video. I hope you enjoyed it. You know,
so now you can see what I do during the day in my life. And uh, yeah,
I'm pretty happy. I hit two 25, still a long way to go though, but uh, yeah,
I hope you guys would join my journey of getting jacked resell fan.